ينضم الينا من مستشفى ناصر بخان يونس
مراسل الجزيره مؤمن اشرافي وكان هنالك قصف
في محيط المستشفى نتعرف على اخر التطورات
معك
مؤمن نعم زين العابدين منذ اكثر من اربع
ساعات وحتى هذه اللحظه يتواصل القصف
المدفعي الكثيف من قبل الاليات والدبابات
الاسرائيليه المتو من المحور الجنوبي
الشرقي باتجاه
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس وه
المنطقه الفاصله بين مدينتي رفح وخانيونس
وايضا هناك قصف مدفعي ودوي اطلاقات نار
كثيفه من المحور الشمالي الشرقي باتجاه
ايضا المنطقه الغربيه وهي المنطقه الفاصله
بين دير بلح وخانيونس منذ اربع ساعات لم
تتوقف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه عن قصف مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خانيونس وايضا نسمع دوي
اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه من هذين المحور ين ما
اصفر القصف المدفعي حتى هذه اللحظه ما وصل
مجمع ناصر وعبر مواطنون مواطنين انتشلوا
جثامين شهداء 12 شهيد منذ اربع ساعات
بينهم ثلاث اطفال وسيده بالاضافه الى عدد
كبير من الجرحى جميعهم من الاطفال والنساء
والحديث بحسب افادات شهود العيان الذين
يصلون الى مستشفى ناصر وايضا من مسعفين من
الدفاع المدني فان هناك عددا من الشهداء
في مناطق متفرقه لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف
في ساعات الليل المتاخر وفي ظل القصف
المدفعي والغارات الجويه الكثيفه الوصول
اليهم لانتشال جثامينهم وايضا اجلاء عدد
من الجرحى في عدد من المناطق والوصول بهم
الى مستشفى ناصر مع الكثافه ال الكبيره
التي تستخدمها طائرات الاحتلال نسمع الان
دوي انفجارات عنيفه ناجمه عن قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي في هذا المحور هو المحور الجنوبي
الشرقي الذي تنطلق منه وتتوغل الاليات وال
[موسيقى]
نعم الاشتباكات هي محاولات من المقاومه
التصدي للتقدم الاسرائيلي باتجاه المنطقه
الغربيه انطلاقا من المحور الجنوبي الشرقي
من مدينه خانيونس نسمع دوي اطلاقات ناريه
كثيفه كما تسمعوني
الان
سواء من قبل الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
او من قبل محاولات من المقاومين التصدي
ومنع
توغل الدبابات واليات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه حتى
هذه اللحظه لا نعرف الهدف الذي تسعى اليه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال هذه ال
اليه العسكريه الجديده من الانطلاقه من
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي والتي تستمر
وتتواصل حتى هذه اللحظه منذ اربع ساعات
وسط قصف مدفعي كثيف اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه
ناجمه عن اشتباكات ضاريه وعنيفه في هذه في
هذه المنطقه وهذا المحور على وجه التحديد
منذ اربع ساعات لم تتوقف اطلاقات الناريه
كثيفه ولم يتوقف القصف المدفعي ويتخللها
ايضا غارات جويه من قبل الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي يستهدف اراض زراعيه وربما غطاء
تتقدم الاليات منجال غطاء جويع
الان الانفجارات قريبه من محيط مجمع ناصر
ومن بالقرب من الحي النمساوي والمقبره
المحاذيه للحي النمساوي الاليات تحاول
التقدم تحت غطاء ناري كثيف سواء من قبل
المدفعيه او من قبل البوارج الحربيه من
الجهه الرابطه على الساحل الغربي لمدينه
خانيونس وايضا بغطاء جوي كثيف من قبل
المقاتلات الحربيه والطائرات المصيره التي
تار بين الفينه
والاخرى في محيط مجمع ناصر وايضا مناطق
متفرقه من مدينه خان
يونس
بالاضافه الى هذا المحور زين العابدين
هناك المحور الشمالي الشرقي من مدينه
خانيونس المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تكثف من
اطلاق القذائف الصاروخيه تجاه منازل
المواطنين وايضا الابراج السكنيه القريبه
من الساحل الغربي من هذا المحور حيث
استهدفت ابراج طيبه في ابراج طيبه وصلت
جثامين عدد من الشهداء بينهم اطفال
بالاضافه الى اصابات نتيجه قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي استهدف شققا سكنيه في هذه
الابراج والعائله التي وصلت وتمكنت من
الوصول في ساعات الليل الى مستشفى ناصر هي
عائله نازحه من مدينه غزه نزحت الى مدينه
خان يونس هذه المنطقه الجنوبيه التي يدعي
جيش الاحتلال انها منطقه امنه ويدفع بسكان
غزه والشمال لتوجه اليها او سكان المنطقه
الوسطى بالتوجه اليها يلاحقهم بالصواريخ
الحربيه سواء من قبل المقاتلات الحربيه او
من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وا يكثف
غاراته على مدينه خانيونس خلال الساعات
الاربع الاخيره نتحدث عن 12 شهيدا وصلوا
الى مجمع ناصر الطبي عبر سيارات مدنيه من
قبل مواطنين حاولوا انقاذ عدد من الشهداء
لكن اصاباتهم الخطيره ادى الى ارتفاع هذا
العدد من الشهداء حسب افادات من وصل الى
المستشفى يقولون ان هناك عدد من الشهداء
في مناطق متفرقه من مدينه خان يونس لا
يستطيعون الوصول اليهم وانتشالهم والاتيان
بهم الى مجمع ناصر الطب وايضا هناك اصابات
داخل عدد من المنازل تعرضت لقصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي في هذا في ساعات الليل المتاخر
طواقم الاسعاف عاجزه تماما سواء التابعه
لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر او وزاره او وزاره
الصحه من التحرك خارج اسوار مستشفى ناصر
او خارج اسوار
مستشفى الامل حيث مركز الاسعاف التابع
للهلال الاحمر نتيجه كثافه الغارات
الاسرائيليه والقصف المدفعي اسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى الطائرات المسيره من نوع
اكواد كابتر التي تطلق نيرانها على مختلف
المناطق سواء هنا في محيط مجمع ناصر او
محيط مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر وكافه المناطق لا تستطيع سيارات
الاسعاف الخروج في هذا في ساعات الليل
المتاخر دون تنسيق من الصليب الاحمر ولا
نعرف حتى الان هدف العمليه العسكريه
الجديده لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتقدم
من المحور الجنوبي الشرقي باتجاه المنطقه
الغربيه ساحل مدينه خانيونس او النيران
الكثيفه التي تطلقها الدبابات والاليات
المتمركزه في منطقه الكتيبه وشارع خمسه
باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه من المحور الشمالي
الشرقي و ووسط توقعات بان هناك محاولات ل
الاطباق على مدينه خان يونس من الجهه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه
اومن الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه
وهي المناطق فاصله ما بين مدينتي رفعه
وخانيونس وايض
ما بين مدينتي خان يونس ودير البلح يعني
في هذه الحاله اذا الاليات تتقدم من
الشمال الشرقي والجنوب
الشرقي ناحيه غرب خانيونس وساحل خانيونس
نعم لكن حتى هذه اللحظه زين العابدين لم
تصل الى ساحل مدينه خنوس او الى المنطقه
الغربيه تماما لم تطبق تماما على المدينه
ولا نعرف حتى هذه اللحظه هدف هذه العمليه
هل هي عمليه ستستمر لساعات ومع شروق شمس
يوم غد تنسحب الاليات في ساعات الصباح
الباكر كما جرت العاده ام هي ستستمر في
هذه العمليه او التوغل البري الجديد ولا
نعرف طبيعه الاهداف حتى هذه اللحظه التي
يسعى اليها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خاصه
بعد تصريحات وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف
جلنت عن توسيع حديثي عن توسيع ال اليه
العسكريه في مدينه خان يونس ومع اجداد
وتيره المعارك منذ ثلاث ايام تقريبا
لاحظنا ورصدنا تصاعدا كبيرا في وتيره
الاشتباكات والمعارك الضاريه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
كافه محاور التوغل سواء في المحور الجنوبي
الشرقي منطقه قيزان النجار منطقه معن او
المحور الشرقي ببلدات المختلفه من بني
سهيله الى خزاعه الى الزنه او المحور
الشمالي الشرقي محيط بلده القراره ومنطقه
الكتيبه ومحيط ايضا منطقه البلد وسط
خانيونس التي تحاول منذ اكثر من ع ايام
قوات الاحتلال التوغل عبر دباباتها الى
تلك المنطقه لكنها تعتلي البنايات العاليه
والمرتفعه في منطقه البلد في وسط مدينه
خان يونس من قبل قناصه جيش الاحتلال الذين
يستهدفون المواطنين الذين يحاولون الوصول
الى منطقه البلد لانتشال جثامين عدد من
الشهداء ف تمنعهم قوات الاحتلال عبر اطلاق
النار المباشر ما ادى الى ارتقاء اربعه من
الشهداء فقط في محيط منطقه البلد ممن
حاولوا الوصول اليها لانتشال جثامين شهداء
وايضا تستهدف طواقم الاسعاف التي باتت
عاجزه خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه عن
الوصول الى مختلف اماكن التوغل او التي
تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء او اجلاء الجرحى او حتى اجلاء
العائلات المحاصره داخل داخل منازلها في
حاره زعرب في منطقه خيزان النجار ومناطق
متف فرقه تتوغل بها قوات الاحتلال لا
تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف والدفاع المدني
الوصول اليها لاجلاء هذه العائلات
وانتقالهم واجلاهم الى مناطق اكثر امنا
بعيدا عن القذائف والصواريخ الاسرائيليه
لكن في حقيقه الامر لا يوجد مكان امن في
مدينه خان يونس من شرقها الى غربها ومن
شمالها الى جنوبها الجميع في مرمى
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه ونيران جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقناصه بالنسبه لهذه المنطقه
الغربيه وساحل خالون الذي تتقدم اليه
الاليات الاسرائيليه من الشمال الشرقي
والجنوب
الشرقي ما المعلومات المتاحه
عن عدد سكانه كنا نشاهد الناس في في طوال
هذه الحرب يلجؤون الى الشاطئ
لكي يبتعدوا عن المعارك يرجعون للشاطئ لكي
يغسلوا ملابسهم نشاهد
معك في
محيط زين
العابدين ناس يبدو طلقات ناريه من كواد
كابتر طائرات فوق رؤوسنا مباشره
اي من طائرات مسيره اسرائيليه تطلق
النيران في محيط مجمع ناصر وفي
اجوائه وسط الاشتباكات الدائره والقريبه
من المنطقه الجنوبيه مجمع ناصر
اي منطقه غرب خن يونس على وجه التحديد زين
العابدين هي منطقه المواصي هي المنطقه
التي دع اسمع انفجار كبير الان في
محيطنا يعني الاصوات تقترب منك كثيرا مؤمن
هذه
شذيه الاصوات تقترب
وشظايا القذائف الاسرائيليه
تتطاير في محيط المنطقه التي نتواجد بها
داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي وهو مجمع ومستشفى
مهم ورئيسي في المنطقه الجنوبيه لم يكن في
عموم قطاع غزه بعد خروج مستشفى الشفاء عن
الخدمه نتيجه الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
المباشر لمستشفى
الشفاء والوضع صعب جدا هنا سواء على صعيد
الاطقم الطبيه او المرضى او الجرحى او حتى
النازحين الذين لجوا الى داخل المستشفى
للاحتماء داخل
اسواره يعني لا ادري ان كان من الممكن
المواصله معكم
امير تكون في مكان نحن بجانب بجانب جدار
نحن بخير زين العابدين نحن بجانب جدار
المستشفى بجانب جدار لكن ما ما سمعت ابدا
في مداخله معك
مؤمن الاصوات تقترب بهذا الشكل يعني يبدو
انها قريبه جدا هل تستطيع ان تحدد اين هي
تحديدا
الان هي في المنطقه الجنوبيه من مجمع ناصر
ما تسمعونه من اشتباكات واطلاق ناريه
كثيفه سواء من قبل المقاومه التي تحاول
الحيلوله دون تقدم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تجاه المنطقه الغربيه او من
قبل الدبابات التي لا تسير ولا تتقدم مترا
واحدا دون غطاء ناري كثيف سواء من قبل
المدفعيه او من قبل الطائرات المسيره التي
تغطي سماء مدينه خان يونس او من قبل حتى
المقاتلات الحربيه التي تستهدف الاراضي
الزراع
وتمهد الطريق للتوغل باتجاه المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس حتى هذه اللحظه
لا
نعرف الى اين وصلت هذه الدبابات والاليات
الاسرائيليه في المحور الجنوب لكننا
نسمع دوي اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه من قبل
الدبابات والاليات وايضا طائرات مروحيه
اسرائيليه يبدو هي من تطلق الان نيرانها
في الاجواء في هذه المنطقه
اي على ذكر المنطقه الامنه ادعى جيش
الاحتلال ان منطقه المواص الغربيه مدينه
النوس هي منطقه امنه دع السكان الى نزول ر
ان تكون منطقه امن
تلاحقهم كان يفترض ان تكون منطقه امنه
ويتجمع فيها كل سكان الوسط
والجنوب وحتى كان هنالك انتقالات من وسائل
الاعلام الغربيه انها لا تعاد حتى مساحه
هيسو لكي يجتمع فيها مليون و300 الف الان
هذه المنطقه تدخل اليها الاليات
الاسرائيليه ليس
كذلك نعم هي تحاول الدخول والتقدم الى هذه
المنطقه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يصل الى
منطقه
اي المواصي المنطقه المتاخمه للساحل
الغربي من مدينه خان يونس بحسب ما افدنا
به اي والطائرات المصيره ايضا تطلق
نيرانها هو يدفع حتى حتى النازحين الذين
لجوا الى مدينه خان يونس منذ بدايه الحرب
هم هو دفعهم باتجاه مدينه رفح هذه المدينه
الحدوديه
اي لا تمتلك ادنى المقومات لاستقبال هذه
الاعداد الهائله نتحدث زين العابدين عن
اكثر من نصف سكان قطاع غزه ما يقارب مليون
و500 ال نسمه يتواجدون الان في هذه
المدينه الحدوديه الصغيره ولا توجد بها
خدمات اساسيه لاستيعاب هذه الاعداد
الهائله من النازحين سواء على
صعيد المراكز الطبيه او على صعيد المدارس
المدارس امتلات عن بكره ابيها والتي تحولت
الى مراكز الجامعات امتلات عن بكره ابيها
في مدينه رفح وايضا الناس افترشوا الارض
في الساحات العامه وفي الشوارع العامه
نصبوا خياما بسيطه من النيلون الرقيق في
هذا الجو وهذه الجو البارد جدا في في
اربعينيه فصل
الشتاء هو يدفع من تبقى ايضا في مدينه
خانيونس يدفعه باتجاه مدينه رفح حتى سك
سكان مدينه خنوس والمناطق والمربعات
السكنيه التي لم يطلب من سكانها اخلائها
لكن السكان من شده القصف الذي لا يتوقف
على مدار الساعه في مدينه خانون سواء
المدفع او الغارات الجويه او الاستهدافات
من قبل الطائرات المسيره ويدفع بهم باتجاه
مدينه رفح التي ضاقت هذه المدينه بما رحبت
على هذا العدد الكبير اكثر من نصف سكان
قطاع غزه في هذه المدينه الصغيره الحدوديه
سنعود اليك مؤمن لنعرف تطورات هذه
المعارك وهذا التوغل الاسرائيلي من الجنوب
الشرقي والشمال الغربي باتجاه ساحل خان
يونس منطقه
المواصي وان شاء
الله يعني نتمنى السلامه لجميع اهالي غزه
ول الصحفيين وطواقم
الطبيه